okay i've watched the first episode of
she-hulk the lawyer me two things stuck
out at me first is just how terrible the
closing argument was at the end my
client was well within his right
to protect his business interest these
accidental deaths were an unfortunate
byproduct of an ambitious expansion plan
okay that's just a terrible argument
both legally and persuasively that a
bunch of people died because you were
ambitiously expanding your business uh
that's not gonna work did my client know
lives would be endangered
that is debatable
and depends on your definition of
knowing that's a terrible argument that
it depends on the definition of knowing
that other people are going to die uh
that's bad legally and persuasively just
an all-around terrible argument that
just seems like they threw a bunch of
legal words together but at least there
was one bright spot at the very
beginning of the episode as they do a
slow pull away from jennifer walters
it's revealed that she has two degrees
both of which are from ucla obviously
the best law school out there go bruins